now we're going to Florida where
protesters rallied at the state capitol
against a series of bills brought by a
conservative control legislature those
bills include easing of gun laws an
expansion of the state's so-called don't
say gay Bill the legislative wins would
be a big boost for governor round
DeSantis who appears to be making a push
to run for president Ed O'Keefe is in
Tallahassee with more on that part of
the story Ed good morning to you
Gail great to see you Governor DeSantis
is waiting for the end of a marathon
legislative session before making it
official there's been passage of a
handful of popular bipartisan bills but
it's the conservative proposals passed
with just Republican votes that are
likely to serve as the springboard for
the Governor's entry into the GOP
Presidential primary
I think you'll have seen the most
productive uh six-month stretch than
anybody he could can remember Florida's
Republican state legislature is putting
the finishing touches on dozens of bills
all headed to the desk of Governor Ron
DeSantis on Wednesday it was an
expansion of the so-called don't say gay
bill that now restricts any instruction
about sexual orientation or gender
identity up to 8th grade State Senate
President Kathleen pasodomo defended the
focus on an issue critics say unfairly
targets gay and transgender students
that's not what it is it's protecting
our children from harmful materials in
our schools and critics are rallying
against bills that ban abortion Services
after six weeks of pregnancy or relax
concealed carry laws Democrats like
representative Fentress Driscoll can do
little to stop their passage if you look
at the actual policies that he's passed
here they've all been anti-freedom
DeSantis has spent the last few months
mostly on the road selling his Memoir in
early presidential primary States
and in Israel Japan South Korea and the
United Kingdom burnishing a thin foreign
policy record
all while former president and Florida
resident Donald Trump hits his potential
political rival who's trailing in recent
polls the Sanctus is very low and
crashing he's crashing and burning the
CBS News poll gives Trump a double-digit
lead over the governor but the same poll
shows Republican primary voters want a
candidate who challenges so-called woke
ideas opposes gun restrictions and makes
liberals angry allies would say that's
exactly what the Santos is doing Florida
is where woke goes to die while many
Republicans are starting to pick sides
others relish the focus on the Florida
Front Runners I think anyone who wants
to run for president from the state of
Florida
is great
now one other thing the GOP LED
legislature has done is clarified
Florida law saying that a sitting
Governor doesn't have to resign the job
in order to run for president
right now that piece of legislation
benefits just one Floridian Governor
DeSantis who's expected to sign the bill
Tony
that's an important point there at
O'Keefe for us Ed thank you very much